this is a portrait of Joseph Priestley
the discoverer of oxygen he was quite a
radical thinker and he lived in the UK
but towards the end of his life he moved
to the United States but he discovered
oxygen here in the UK before he
emigrated I should say that there was a
parallel discovery by Sheila but I want
to talk about Priestley not about the
oxygen because before he left the United
States
he gave a present to somebody here in
the UK and I want to see it I never seen
it before so let's go and have a look
the present is in this little box let's
open it and look at it together there's
a leather case in this our Priestly's
spectacles I think they're very exciting
I was just thinking the frames are
rather trendy by modern standards
because look this is tortoiseshell I
think but what is interesting is you can
see that the side pieces move outwards
like this he can't have had such a small
head I think they must have been
designed to give a sort of spring effect
so they didn't fall off his nose nobody
knows whether Priestley was
short-sighted or not I suppose the only
thing to do is actually to look through
the glasses and see they'd seem pretty
powerful I can see nothing through them
at all and I think he had a smaller head
than me so I went right on I might break
them
they clearly weren't safety glasses so
if it had an accident it would have been
dangerous for him it says on here
dr. Priestley born 17:33 died 1804 so
there's a nice label on it really
showing it that there were his glasses
and I think in those days these were
very expensive and valuable item so it
was worth giving it to somebody else
when my glasses wear out I just throw
them away or dump them in the drawer and
never given them to anybody else I
didn't think anybody'd want them that's
not an invitation to you on YouTube to
write in for them I didn't get them and
very often and I haven't got many now I
think what is interesting is that even
at that time he was a sufficiently
respected person that the Society's
preserved his glasses some scientists
when they make a discovery the
importance of their discoveries not
realized till many many years afterwards
everything's been thrown away but this
shows that Priestley's work must have
been valued at the time he made oxygen
out of mercuric oxide the compound with
one atom of mercury one atom of oxygen
and it is said that what he did was to
focus sunlight using a large lens onto a
sample of this mercuric oxide which is a
red colored compound or orange red and
it dissociated to give oxygen and
Mercury which is a silver metal so he
could see fairly easily that the
reaction had taken place and he
collected the gas and this was the gas
that he analyzed he didn't call it
oxygen but that name was coined later
there's also it's said that he invented
carbonated water
komm dioxide in water which is what the
fizzy drinks that you and I drink now
and
so probably his more famous for oxygen
but perhaps fizzy drinks have a bigger
impact on our everyday life now the
Royal Society is putting on an
exhibition which is going on from now
until May 2013 on romantic chemistry
where you can see some of these papers
you can see Priestley's glasses and all
sorts of other interesting artifacts so
come along and learn a bit more
chemistry